We've already written one version
of a Mad Libs generator, but
there are couple parts
that could be improved.
Namely, we want to be able
to not only replace noun and
verb, but any other substitute that we
wanted, like adjective, person or name.
Now, just like the last Mad Libs
generator you wrote, there are many ways
that you can build this and I encourage
you to try and implement your own way.
But I'll show you the way
that I approach this problem,
which I'll use for loops, and lists.
Let's say we have this string mad_lib1,
which is equal to I
can VERB around PLACE.
In this string,
the words we want to replace with
user input are VERB and PLACE.
However, what if we had this other
sentence mad_lib2 is equal to
NAME is what they call PLURAL NOUN.
Since we want our function to be able to
handle replacements, like place, name,
plural noun and
other words we may add in the future,
why don't we create a list of words,
which I'll call Partis Beach and
set it equal to a working list of
possible replacement words, like so.
Since the words I know I want to replace
so far are VERB, PLACE, NAME and NOUN,
in this example I'll set my parts_of_speech
equal to a list of those strings.
Now that we have a list of word we want
to replace, how do we use it to create
a Mad Libs generator that
replaces words with user input?
I said that the string dot split
function would come in handy and
this is where we'll use it.
If we split the string mad
lib on the blank space,
we'll now have each word
in the list element.
We'll also create this empty list,
replaced, which you'll see how
it'll be used in just a second.
Now that we have our three list setup,
parts_of_speech,
split madlib, and replaced, let's go
over how we'll solve this problem.
General idea is to
iterate through madlib,
check if the current iteration or
word rom contains a part of speech, and
if it does, we'll prompt the user
to enter their replacement word for
that part of speech, and then add that
user input to word to the list replaced.
If the word isn't in parts_of_speech,
we'll simply add the word we're
looking at to replaced instead.
So let's run through an example
using the split mad_lib1.
So the first thing I
look at is the string I.
Is this in parts_of_speech?
No, it's not.
So I'll add it to replaced.
Next, I look at can.
Is this in parts_of_speech?
It isn't, so I'll add it to replaced.
Now I look at VERB.
Is this in parts_of_speech?
It is, so
I'll prompt the user to give me a verb.
And let's say I put in jump.
I'll now add that to replaced.
Since around isn't in parts_of_speech,
And now we're at PLACE.
Now this is where things
get a bit interesting.
Now notice that there was this
period at the end of place.
Since we want to keep all punctuation,
we're going to have to make our
approach a little bit more robust.
Well, first you need to check that the
string PLACE is in the string PLACE with
a period rather than just comparing
the two words for equality.
Now we'll need to replace just
the word PLACE with the user input, so
we keep the period.
And then, add their replacement word
with a period to the list replaced.
So let's say I put in Italy for PLACE.
Replaced will now have Italy
with a period at the end of it,
as a last element of the list.
And there we go, now we have
a list with the replacement words.
The only thing we need to do now,
is change this list back into a string.
We already know how to convert strings
to lists by using the split function.
Now I'll show you just one more
function that's the reverse of that.
Join.
As you can see what
we'll be joining on and
the string to join are in opposite
positions of the split function.
But no need to worry.
If we join on replace like this,
our output will be a string that's
equal to I can jump around Italy.
Now, the real beauty of this approach
is that we can add any words that we
want to replace to our
parts_of_speech list, and
our generator will work just the same.
Now that we've gone over the general
solution we want to implement,
it's time to write some code.